les voy a pedir que lean estos versos y
piensen si su origen es una canción de
reggaeton o un poema
al pensar en esta plática batalla un
poco en saber cómo empezar porque
entiendo que reggaeton es algo que tiene
una connotación negativa para algunas
personas
yo soy de aquí de monterrey que como
sabemos está relativamente cerca a eeuu
y crecí con la idea de que todo era
mejor en inglés el cine la tele
escuchaba muy poca música en español y
tenía esta idea del reggaeton como algo
que era vulgar machista violento y en
general una influencia negativa para la
sociedad
estudié letras en la universidad y los
primeros años llevamos un tronco común
de materias de humanidades que me gustan
porque aprendíamos cosas que eran muy de
cultura general prioridad el punto en el
semestre en que tenía que estudiar para
el examen parcial y me tenían que
aprender lo que yo sentía que eran todas
las obras de todos los museos de italia
y en mi desesperación estudiando me
surgía la duda de por qué era una parte
tan esencial de mi educación nunca si
quiere de italia estudió literatura en
mexico y me di cuenta que no podía
mencionar ni la mitad de los datos
culturales sobre méxico de los que
aprendía sobre europa
me hacía pensar que si yo que estoy una
carrera relacionada al arte a la cultura
no estoy aprendiendo sobre arte y
cultura en méxico entonces quién sí lo
está haciendo desde que haya entrado a
la universidad había planeado hacer un
año de intercambio aunque no tenía muy
segura donde la opción más obvia era
europa como que todos tenemos este azul
consciente de querer escapar del tercer
mundo no pero después esta experiencia
me di cuenta que ya aprendía lo
suficiente sobre europa y decidí buscar
un intercambio en latinoamérica viví un
año en buenos aires y para mí fue muy
evidente desde el principio que
argentina y méxico eran lugares muy
diferentes
nada te hace cuestionar tanto que tu
concepto y la realidad como que haga
frío en verano combinado con que hablan
español rarísimo ya veces las mismas
palabras tenían significados diferentes
me acuerdo que yo llegué al lugar donde
me estaba hospedando ofreciendo paletas
de cajeta y dijeron que nunca volver a
decir eso en mi vida
lo curioso fue que la mayoría de la
gente que conocí terminaron siendo otros
alumnos de intercambio que la mayoría
eran europeos así como nosotros buscamos
escapar a europa a otros lugares del
mundo al parecer ellos también buscan
irse lo más lejos posible y terminaron
conmigo en buenos aires
esto me puso en una situación muy
particular porque me di cuenta que había
cosas de argentina que yo sí entendía
por ser latinoamericana y ellos no cosas
como el tiempo que te decían que la
fiesta empezaba a las 10 para que
llegaras antes de las 12 aunque el metro
pagara cada cinco minutos pero es como
aprox cada cinco minutos y otras
situaciones como dramas políticos son
noticias de corrupción que a mí se me
hacían el pan de todos los días y ellos
no entendían porque no era noticia
internacional y no estaba interviniendo
la onu y estando allá también empecé a
escuchar más reggaeton por dos razones
la primera es que si salían más de
fiesta que aquí en monterrey pero
también creo que fue un muy buen año
para el reggaeton fue cuando salía
despacito y me daba cuenta que el
reggaeton también en estas cosas que yo
entendía de una manera que mis amigos
europeos tal vez no todo el trasfondo de
esta música como un gusto culposo que
hablaba de cosas escondidas que no
queríamos saber de la sociedad
combinado con que en mis clases en
argentina ya clases de literatura
latinoamericana y leíamos mucha poesía y
a mí no se me hacía tan alejado lo que
escuchaba en el reggaeton de lo que leía
tal vez de pablo neruda o mario
benedetti que son los autores de los
versos que les enseña el principio
cuando regrese a monterrey llevé un
taller de poesía en el que todos tenemos
que escribir un poemario en mi se me
hizo buenísima idea hacer poemas de
reggaeton para cada poema y va a
combinar versos de diferentes canciones
que tenían temáticas similares
pero el nuestro no me conocía y tal vez
cometí el pequeñísimo error de decir que
si pablo neruda fuera millennials sería
reguetonero entonces me batearon la idea
y tuve que hacerlo sobre otra cosa pero
yo estaba muy convencida que era una muy
buena idea y pasaron años en los que yo
voy a escuchar todos los días oyendo
gasolina a las 7 de la mañana para
empezar el día al 100 que meta escuchar
reggaeton en la mañana es igual de
efectivo que tomar café y entre más
reggaetón escuchadas más ciudad se me
ocurrían y las apuntando todas
y en mi último año de la universidad
llevé un seminario de literatura
comparada en el que veíamos temas ajenos
desde el punto de vista de la literatura
vimos si medimos cómics hasta la biblia
y para esta materia que era con el mismo
maestro del taller de poesía teníamos
que hacer una investigación con este
enfoque de la literatura comparada y
claro que le dije al profesor que ya no
me podía negar hacer un proyecto sobre
el reggaetón el mismo maestro que me
bateó el primer proyecto fue el que me
dio la oportunidad de hacer el segundo y
las metas son buenos maestros y se lo
agradezco muchísimo termine esa materia
con una presentación de una hora y media
que de background tiene una playlist que
se iba de reto mi equipo lo más nuevo
expuse absolutamente todo lo que llevaba
años recopilando sobre reggaetón
lo primero que tenemos que hacer para
explorar el reggaeton desde la
literatura es definir qué es literatura
dice que literatura es el arte de la
expresión verbal esta definición no me
explica absolutamente nada pero si deja
la puerta abierta a la expresión verbal
puede ser oral como escrita porque
históricamente antes de que hubiera
literatura escrita ya se contaban
historias de boca en boca
una definición que alguna vez surgió
sobre qué es literatura y muy
cercanamente que es arte también es el
reflejo de la condición humana dentro de
un contexto es decir si leemos la odisea
podemos entender cómo era vivir en
grecia en la antigüedad o si leemos a
jane o usted no las hermanas brontë
podemos entender cómo era la experiencia
de ser mujer en inglaterra en el siglo
19 italo calvino tenía una definición de
literatura similar a ésta decía que la
literatura es una herramienta de
autoconciencia cultural o sea que una
cultura puede conocerse a sí misma a
través de su literatura
entiendo porque mi maestro me mate o la
primera vez que quise explorar el
reggaeton desde la literatura porque a
veces pensamos en la literatura como
algo demasiado puro como la cima de la
humanidad pero se nos olvidan que
recientemente bob dylan un músico fue
quien ganó el premio nobel de literatura
la verdad es que la literatura al igual
que el lenguaje y la condición humana
misma son cosas que cambian dependiendo
del uso que se les da y se adaptan
constantemente
una de las pocas investigaciones que
encontré sobre el tema hablaba de lo
importante que es para la literatura
estudiar cosas de cultura popular como
lo es el reggaetón decía
una literatura que no tiene en cuenta lo
que la gente canta como la gente baila
qué canciones utiliza para definir sus
relaciones amorosas o sus luchas
cotidianas es una literatura que no
presta atención a los nuevos modos de
expresión que a fin de cuentas está
alejada de la realidad entonces ahora sí
de qué manera el reggaetón puede ser una
herramienta de autoconciencia cultural
el reggaetón ya 15 años siendo la música
más escuchada en latinoamérica tiene en
sus inicios un movimiento de
contracultura que se oponía a los
valores tradicionales establecidos sus
raíces son cercanas a la vida de
poblaciones marginadas que representan
una parte de la realidad latinoamericana
que existe como género aunque tienen sus
orígenes musicales en movimientos de los
80 y los 90 s el reggaetón sólo ha
existido de manera popular en el siglo
21 y dentro de las letras del reggaetón
podemos identificar imágenes muy
latinoamericanas y super el siglo 21 por
ejemplo o por su noche en el pueblo
ahora me gustó transitar y el que vive
por bayamón a mí ya no me calla yo no
soy un poco
lado están las referencias a elementos
muy del siglo 21 como el nokia o el
pokemon no estan aterrizadas en
latinoamérica con el perreo la sicaria
bayamón
estas líneas no son las más memorables
pero el retorno está lleno de ellas son
como joyitas escondida dentro de las
canciones que crean símbolos de nuestro
contexto y que en su totalidad forman
como un muy void de cómo es
latinoamérica en el siglo 21 una de las
herramientas que usa en exceso el
reggaeton es la intertextualidad aunque
en el mundo de la música se llama
sampling desde la perspectiva de la
literatura lo podemos identificar como
intertextualidad
este concepto se usa en el estudio de la
lingüística y hay autores como gérard
genette o julia kristeva que tienen
libros y ensayos enteros dedicados al
tema
una definición muy concreta de tener
sobre la intertextualidad es todo lo que
pone al texto en relación manifiesta o
secreta con otros textos
en la literatura sucede por ejemplo en
100 años de soledad garcía márquez
incluyen la narrativa a artemio cruz' un
personaje del autor mexicano carlos
fuentes también en ocasiones menciona
rocamador de rayuela de julio cortázar
oa víctor hugo de la novela del siglo de
las luces de alejo carpentier aunque
estos personajes no son protagonistas de
100 años de soledad el hecho de que
estén incluidos hace que el lector los
puede identificar dentro del mismo
universo garcía márquez hasta menciona a
otros personajes de sus propios cuentos
que el lector entiende existen dentro
del mismo mundo es como con las
películas de marvel que estás viendo
todos y de repente sale folk y tiene
sentido que estén juntos porque existen
dentro del mismo universo
en el reggaeton pasa cuando se hacen
todo tipo de referencias a otras
canciones
normalmente el reggaeton viejito o
clásico que sería el de hace 15 años
a veces son como el flow o el ritmo de
una canción puesta en otra
pero la intertextualidad de reggaeton
más fácil de identificar es cuando se
usan exactamente las mismas letras y aún
mejor todavía las canta el mismo artista
no no
[Música]
y yo
la verdad
si en la literatura la intertextualidad
hace que el lector puede identificar un
universo con todos los mismos personajes
en el reggaeton de igual manera crea una
red en la que las experiencias que se
narran son compartidas el conflicto más
grande que se me ha presentado cuando
quiero hablar de mi interés por el
reggaetón es que yo sé una mujer que
quiere defender el reggaetón muchas
personas hombres en especial me intentan
explicar que no me puedo decir feminista
y al mismo tiempo escuchar a barbón y
que se me hace muy curioso que siempre
use nevadas bonitas como bandera el
machismo porque se me hace uno de los
menos mitos pero bueno
la palabra muchísimo es una palabra
latinoamericana originaria de aquí o sea
surge en latinoamérica por la necesidad
de describir un comportamiento que
sucede en todo el continente si estamos
diciendo que el reggaetón transmite la
experiencia latinoamericana en el siglo
21 pues es obvio que haber letras
machistas y que las vamos a poder
identificar en las canciones
precisamente porque el machismo es parte
de la experiencia latinoamericana
pero así como hay machismo en
latinoamérica también más recientemente
el feminismo las masculinidades y más
aceptación de la diversidad y eso
también se refleja en el reggaetón se
muestra con reggaetón nuevas feministas
como hay de queens desde los inicios
hasta mis niñas más recientemente pero
se muestra también la masculinidad
en los estudios de género existen
ciertas características que se
consideran fundamentales para la
masculinidad tradicional helmand barker
y harrison proponen 7
autosuficiencia fortaleza atractivo
físico roles de género rígidos
heterosexualidad de homofobia
hipersexualidad y agresión y control
en el reggaeton actual existen
narrativas desde el punto de vista
masculino que no siempre encajan
exactamente con estos pilares por
ejemplo
[Música]
no me vas a decir verdad
yo no soy tuyo ni de nadie yo soy sólo
mí
en la primera canción indecisión se está
describiendo una situación muy reguetón
no está el hombre que narra la canción
viendo una chava que le gusta bailar
pero ya no describe cómo va sin miedo
como imponerse súper macho la situación
le causa indecisión está hablando de un
momento de vulnerabilidad que no es una
característica muy tradicionalmente
masculina
lo mismo con la segunda canción de bad
bonnie que se convirtió en un himno de
autor y autocuidado que son
características más tradicionalmente
femeninas que hombres narran canciones
así habla ya de un cambio en la
experiencia de ser hombre en
latinoamérica
quiero aclarar que con esto no quiero
decir que se tienen que aceptar lo que
es machista porque es parte de la
cultura para nada sí me gusta mucho el
reggaeton como tales ya se dieron cuenta
pero claro que hay artistas que evito y
hasta me caen mal así como me gusta
mucho la literatura de latinoamericana y
no necesariamente me encantan todos los
autores y cuentos y novelas y poemas que
existen
pero asumir que todo el reggaeton es
machista es ignorar la diversidad de
contenidos que ofrece que es un reflejo
de la diversidad de experiencias
latinoamericanas
predomina el machismo en el reggaeton
porque predomina en la sociedad pero no
es lo único que hay y lo único que va a
ver para siempre tal vez como en este
momento la música que se produce utiliza
frases de canciones viejitas en la
intertextualidad del reggaetón en un
futuro las letras en las que se haga
referencia van a hacer estas nuevas como
no me vuelvas a decir bebe el reggaeton
beer cambiando como reflejo de la
evolución social cultural
esta es una de las maneras como podemos
conocer y estudiar el progreso de la
cultura latinoamericana en el reggaeton
así es como el reggaeton puede ser una
herramienta de autoconciencia cultural
se me hace muy chistoso que todo este
interés y tiempo y esfuerzo que le he
puesto a pensar tanto sobre el reggaetón
haya iniciado por haber vivido en
argentina definitivamente no elegir a
buenos aires para aprender sobre el
reggaeton pero creo que esta apertura a
ver las similaridades entre mi
experiencia mexicana con otras
experiencias latinoamericanas me abrió
las puertas para poder ver el reggaetón
como algo que también es parte de
nuestra cultura compartida
mucho tiempo después me he cuestionado
que tanto el preferir ver tele en inglés
el pensar que vale más la pena estudiar
arte italiano la idea subyacente de
creer escapar del tercer mundo es un
rechazo en nosotros mismos de no pensar
que podemos hacer arte y cultura y
entretenimiento a la misma altura que el
primer mundo llegó a la conclusión de
que también es algo muy latinoamericano
el tenerle vergüenza a hacer del tercer
mundo pero eso solo hace que nos
limitemos a no poder conocernos
para terminar quiero cerrar con la idea
de que el reggaeton ya es demasiado
grande para que sigamos pensando que no
nos representa o que solo es algo que
deteriora la sociedad les voy a enseñar
un tick tock que me encanta de una chava
en inglaterra que está agravándose en un
antro en el baño derrotada por la noche
de fiesta y a lo lejos se escucha que
poner en la pista la icónica canción
gasolina de daddy yankee
estas tiras gas lino y colgaron
[Aplausos]
marcelina
[Música]
cada vez que no importa si estás aquí en
china en inglaterra si ponen gasolina en
la pista del antro tienes que salir a
bailar
el reggaeton es demasiado grande para
nosotros es el producto creativo con
origen en latinoamérica más popular a
nivel global en la actualidad
en cualquier parte del mundo que pongan
reggaeton saben que es latinoamericano
por eso vale la pena explorar todo el
valor cultural literario que puede
cargar y todo lo que podemos aprender de
latinoamérica a través del reggaeton
[Aplausos]